i would honestly use your data as an
example of this like
when anyone your average person thinks
he's sick
like your average dude is like yo that
guy rules
that would be my opinion right and when
you
so anyone that thinks that when you see
people on the internet saying he said
this and this
you go ah he's just looking for
something you you you would dismiss
their criticisms
so imagine now you were someone that was
all in on black lives matter or all in
on trans stuff
and then you see a conservative being
like well on the black lives matter
website it says this and this you go
shut up you're just looking for
something oh yeah you have an honest
critique of this
like in what scenario would you be for
this
so i think that they are i think that
i get why both sides see critiques from
the other side as
you know in bad faith
welcome to episode 91 of the mckayla
peterson podcast
on this episode i'm joined by ryan long
ryan long is comedian and filmmaker from
toronto
who's currently living and working in
new york he's the creator star and
showrunner of the hit digital series
torontopia
on cbc and has the podcast the boys cast
we discussed his insanely popular
slightly controversial youtube channel
the state of comedy in the time of
heightened cultural divide
how he gets away with somewhat
controversial comedy
how he got into it his inspirations the
subjective and objective components of
comedy
and just chatted i love comedians i want
to speak to more of them
i hope you enjoy this episode if you do
please remember to hit
subscribe
[Music]
ryan long welcome to my podcast hello
i just uh i was on tour for the last
three weeks so i
um i was take i was doing your all meat
diet a version of it but where i just
eat chicken fingers
okay that's definitely a version of it
that's what it is
you survived you're still you're still
alive yeah you're here you don't look
half bad
the all chicken finger died it had the
reverse effect on me though i don't feel
great
that's not surprising at all okay for
anyone who doesn't know who you are can
you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do yeah
i'm a comedian
and that's basically the gist of it but
also
i just moved to america from like uh
about a year and a half ago
um i had like some tv shows and i did a
bunch of traditional media stuff there
and i've been doing comedy forever and
then i moved to america
and i've been i release a video every
monday and have a podcast called the
boys cast
and i tour as a stand-up comic
okay and you said you're in new york
right now yeah
i'm so i was i moved to america
right before the pandemic so i kind of
nailed the timing that's when that's
exactly when you want to show up i
believe
right at the beginning of a pandemic
yeah i was and you left too where are
you now
i'm in dubai oh that see that sounds
that just sounds fancy
it is ridiculously fancy it doesn't just
sound fancy
it's like it's crazy it's like silicon
valley met
vegas and they also have more money like
it it's crazy here
yeah no with uh toronto
like i'm this i'm from around there from
you and i lived in toronto so i was
my friends and stuff that are there it's
when i hear what they're
dealing with right now you know they'll
be like oh i just went you know we went
back into lockdown i'm like this is
crazy saying i can't so when i move i
moved to america right like i said right
before this
i put all my stuff in you know a storage
locker and i go okay i'm gonna come to
america with just a backpack
i kind of figured out where i was gonna
live got all the clubs and stuff like
that
and then i go i was like planning to go
back and get all my stuff and that's
when the pandemic happens so
like i have a car that's sitting in
toronto right now
yeah and and now there's a two-week
quarantine when you go back so you're
just delaying that until that goes away
theoretically
i mean now i own new stuff so at this
point instead i just i go back and
i don't know i think that that stuff
belongs to the streets now
okay fair enough so you've kind of
skyrocketed on youtube in the last
year and a half or so so did you find
some niche
in the market or were you just doing
what you normally do and it just
happened
yeah i was well the thing that i've been
doing i've been doing for a long time so
i basically i built up uh the video
department for this website called the
hard times and i kind of had a ton of
viral videos and then
i did a series at cbc called tron topia
where i had kind of again i had
you know huge digital numbers and i kind
of kept going viral and all this stuff
and i think that on stage i was every
night talking to stuff that i felt like
was resonating with people and
when i when i came to america i was it's
canada's so small right and there's no
room for like a counter culture
especially but when i was
there i really felt like i was you know
touching a nerve and you know having
people come up to me and saying that
so when i came to america i just did the
same thing
with my own channel because it's big
enough and i go okay i'm just gonna kind
of do my own thing here
so when i moved to america i basically
did the same thing on the internet for
my channel that i'd done
a few times before so it wasn't really
that much of a surprise because
you know a lot of people it's like oh
you kind of like popped off on the
internet
i was like yeah but i've done this a lot
of times and i kind of have a system
same with stand up right it kind of
a lot of times these jokes people will
come up and it's like you know how can
you say that and it's
for me i'm like well i've done i know
that i could say that because i've done
that a million times in front of
audiences and i
kind of have a pulse of what's touching
people's nerve at least that's how i
kind of interpret it
so it wasn't really that much of a
surprise because i've done this a few
other times
um but the fact that it happened
so quickly was cool
yeah you have a couple of i've seen a
bunch of your stuff but you have
one and and it's about what um
how racists and woke people are the same
you have a skit
like that or at least when a racist and
a woke person meet
that one that i think that went very
viral that was kind of the hilarious
one that yeah because there was other
ones that were
you know when i first moved here
everyone was especially a lot of the
comedians were very
cool because you know everyone was kind
of like yo who are you you know what i
mean
when i showed up and started doing the
clubs and then
when i started doing the the videos a
lot of people were kind of you know you
guys got to check this guy out he just
moved here i was getting a lot of that
and people reaching out getting me on
their things
which was kind of building my thing and
then by that point i had enough to sort
of have my own platform because again i
started this youtube channel kind of
when i moved here and then
um and then when that video was the
first one that
you know really went crazy yeah well
it's tricky because you're
you're really like walking a fine line
about what's acceptable
and it's kind of funny watching you put
some of these videos out because it's
like
how come this went viral and is okay
like why is it that this guy
is okay and these other people who say
something that's just a tiny little bit
off or like oh now my career is over
so how are you how are you navigating
that have you had
kickback that that could lead to
cancellation or you just not worried
about that at all
well first of i mean for a lot of people
it definitely wasn't okay i mean
you know it definitely got people
ruffled up on the internet and
okay they're always you know my my
twitter feed is non-stop people arguing
but i for one i mean
in terms of navigating that if you i try
to
comedy's a lot different than you know
political speech in that
for most political speech or you know
whether you're a podcaster or something
you kind of capture your audience and
then
you know you become uh at war for them
essentially and i think that happens to
comedians as you get weaponized
but when you're in comedy clubs it's not
just those people there once you're on
tour and you're kind of
speaking your audience but so i'm i'm
trying to be able to make everybody
laugh and that's
what i've found is that it's not that i
i'm not it's that people have a weird
view of you know what the mainstream
opinion is and i think that
when i go to okay you know i mean when
you go to comedy clubs you go
people will go how can you say that in
new york i go i say it every night in
new york
they go but those people are crazy i go
you have the ones on the internet that
are really loud i think
some people spend so much time on the
internet and so that is one of the
things that
i deal with the idea of you know what is
exactly
you know what i'm trying to accomplish
you know what am i trying to do because
it is the there is that paradox of like
weaponization where
you know people kind of that align with
you at that moment
try to take you and then the ones and
then they try to make you their martyr
and then the ones that disagree with you
try to make you the
you know the face of evil and you can
you know in the short term especially i
think you can
you can grow faster from leaning into
that and you can grow slow you know you
can
cause more trouble but then
it is the goal to make great things or
at that point
is the goal to grow or is the goal to
sort of you know get this message across
like
you get a lot of messages when people
agree with you and i'm sure you get the
same thing where people
you know thank you so much for saying
that you're doing this service dust and
you're fighting this fight or whatever
and it's i think it is easy to get
wrapped up in that and i think with
comedy
the greatest comedy that wasn't the goal
that you set out to do
and maybe within it you know they're
supposed to be truth
so i think we're a lot of times it's
kind of funny right now with
comedy really is like a low job it's
you know it's kind of like a scummy
profession you're a pirate in some ways
and if you look at where it started with
you know being the court jester you were
allowed to say anything because you were
that's what that's what your position
was you know that's this guy's this
loser idiot almost right and that gives
you a lot of power and then
i think in in now what's kind of changed
about that a little bit is if you look
at
a lot of these jobs almost became
prestigious you know
especially the big writing jobs you go
to harvard and they're institutions and
you become it's this important thing
right so the more that status grew the
more
you became you know part of the
corporate infrastructure and then the
less
you're able to just say whatever you
want because it's like well i'm just
doing comedy it's like
well not really you're kind of this high
position at this corporate
infrastructure you can't just say
whatever you want now
so you essentially once that happens
it's very hard to say what you want
unless you want to be a propagandist
but people still want to hear that right
so yeah there's
a huge reward there's a huge like i
think reward right now for
uh saying just you know the truth or at
least as you see it or
um you know touching on these nerves of
where you see those energy pockets
but there's also a huge cost to it too
right so um
you just have to navigate your own path
and decide like what your personality is
and i think for me
i was always a bit of a troublemaker and
i'm not
so afraid of those things that uh i was
i think that was the right path for me
and having
been doing this for 20 years i think i'm
like kind of in touch with
where i want to be and how that meets
you know the infrastructure
and it's i won't say one thing there is
um
i think once you start saying that
people start to think that you're
talking about
well it sounds like if you're talking
about navigating and you start using
those words it sounds like
you are it sounds like you know a
careerist kind of
way of talking and that oh so you're are
you only saying these things because
they're
you know popular and it's it's not that
it's just that
you're looking for things that you
already think that haven't been said
before so
you know if you agree there's lots of
topics where i think about making a
video
and maybe i kind of agree with what
everyone already thinks so i don't
really have anything to add to that
conversation
so it's more that i pick you know my
spots of where my you know natural kind
of trouble making instinct or whatever
or my
need to say something um
is at a crossroads with a lot of people
aren't saying that already
yeah yeah that also keeps things more
interesting um
so changing subjects slightly were you
always funny is this something you
learned is this something somebody can
learn
or is this something you just had i
think of it kind of like sports
in that you know you can get better at
anything
but there's there's people that are
better at it than other people
and comedy in a lot of ways is a really
composite skill
in my opinion so there is you know
there's natural talent and
i mean with the videos specifically you
know i was a
pretty successful musician before i ever
did comedy and i had
so i kind of make these videos almost
like music videos and
then also i you know i'm a fairly smart
guy or whatever not
brilliant but you know at least socially
i've you know psychologically i think
i've been always good at pattern
recognition and whatever that kind of
thing is
and then on top of that i was kind of
you know naturally the funny guy
in my group and then the guy but also
the guy that was getting kicked out of
everywhere and all that stuff and i
think that that
combination of things makes up my uh
unit as a comedian so
if you uh some people probably
are i know people that you would say are
you know one percent
funnier than someone else but they're
doing way worse and they're way worse at
it
so it's their their composite skills
right like you know just cause you're
six foot eight doesn't mean you're good
at basketball if you're the most
uncoordinated person but there's
four or five skills that you know kind
of combine this and
one of the things that make you funny is
complete raw talent you know
yeah i've been i've done a lot of
traveling in the last like three or four
years
and i've noticed just from meeting a
whole bunch of different cultures that
sense of humor varies like you get funny
people in every culture but it's
really it really seems cultural to
like british people are are just on
average
way funnier i find than like certain
other
groups there's some people in north
america who are funny too but
have you noticed that at all from
traveling well that
could just be your sensibilities because
you're canadian
right so canadian canada is sort of the
bridge between
american and british comedy and i think
that's why a lot of canadians do really
well here because i do agree
that at its core british humor is more
pure funny i i've kind of always
described it as
americans take medium punch lines
and then sell them as really big and
british people take really big punch
lines and sell them as really small so
it's almost they say really funny jokes
and almost throw them away as they're
nothing you know and it's kind of
there's this
elegance to just you know throwing away
these big punch lines right
and then they're and then people go they
sort of see it a lot of times on stage
and they're like
yeah i don't even really know i was
laughing you barely said anything and
you're like no that's not what happened
you disguised this huge
joke as like nothing and americans it's
always a lot of sauce on less and that's
not across the board but i think canada
canada does well here because i think
canadians a lot of times
understand the american sensibility and
you know simplicity of that um and that
you need to
be a little more clear with what you're
saying and your premises need to
exist so i think that i i agree with you
but if you talk to a lot of americans
they
they don't think the british office was
better than the american office they you
know
that doesn't suit their sensibilities
and if you go to every place probably
has a different thing
but i i would find that i would bet that
you grew up around
since you grew up where around where i
did that maybe that's probably
some of it it's like more intellectual
okay okay that could be it i like that
take take a really funny joke and dab
and just throw it away that is exactly
what they do yeah i
really didn't like the american office i
didn't like it at all it was brutally
painful for me
really michael scott michael scott just
yeah it was just i just cringed the
whole time i watched like four seasons
of it because my boyfriend in high
school was like this is the funniest
thing
and i remember just being like just
hating myself the entire time
well there's also stuff baked into the
american comedy
uh that makes you feel better you know
british comedy is
more tragic and and and american comedy
sort of you know a lot of times lets you
have the happy ending and lets you have
the the feeling of like oh good
you know so there there is something
like cathartic about each of them in
their own way
but british comedy is definitely more
tragic which maybe suits your
sensibilities that's true that's true
self-deprecating yeah yeah surprise i'm
doing an ad in the middle of an episode
mid-roll what can i say they pay more
this ad is brought to you by a company i
think is doing
great things ancestral supplements they
make new zealand-sourced
nose-to-tail organ meat supplements like
beef liver bone marrow
spleen thymus mixed beef organ
supplements
there's more all in gelatin capsules as
you folks probably know i only eat meat
i'm using the diet to treat a very
serious autoimmune and mood disorder
i was deficient in my vitamins prior to
the diet
and most americans are also deficient
even on the standard american diet
especially on the standard american diet
the vitamins you get in pharmacies are
normally not very bioavailable
you basically buy them and end up with
really expensive pee
yep organ supplements are super high in
vitamins like b12
vitamin a vitamin k zinc other b
vitamins
and are actually bioavailable so when
you take them
you get the vitamins you're taking it's
the way i would recommend you get
vitamins if you're deficient
or if you need a boost check out
ancestralsupplements.com to see all
their products
if you're taking a multivitamin i would
seriously consider looking into these
guys instead because they actually have
vitamins your body can absorb
ancestralsupplements.com have insanely
high quality supplements
and now back to ryan long uh what what
kind of comedians gave you
inspiration growing up or learning your
style
so i was so when i was growing up i was
huge into tom green
if you know who that is i'm sure you do
obviously yeah he was like
the guy for me and i when i was playing
in
so i was in this six pretty successful
band in canada right and then
the um we were
i wasn't even into comedy like when i
started doing stand-up i'd probably the
only thing i'd watched
is you know maybe jerry seinfeld special
like i didn't i didn't even know comedy
was like a thing like that but i was
huge into the video guys like i was you
know i was
in insanely big into tom green when i
was
in grade you know four and five i was
making all these videos so i've been you
know making videos okay
doing this stuff for forever how old are
you 35.
okay okay yeah so that that guy was sort
of
huge for me and and that idea of
uh you know doing these kind of things
you're not supposed to do but also for
them the format was something that
you're not supposed to do you're not
supposed to do it like that and i think
that
a lot of times i love the idea of those
jokes where it's like
you're not supposed to do jokes like
that it doesn't what the hell is this
guy doing
you know they sort of invented this new
style i think that's why
even right now if you look at what's
happening with
with comedy there is you know obviously
this divide in
in the world the same way that there's a
divide in every other world because like
all of this
you know culture stuff has influenced
every single thing
and i noticed that it's funny that the
the people on the eve every side wants
to be the victim like you know if you go
you know if i do anything you know talk
to any of these like sort of what would
be considered like conservative people
right
a lot of these people are always you
can't say anything anymore you know
that's their sort of
version of it and it was like no you can
it's just
comedy's always been hard and now the
repercussions are higher
but the but also the
you know the reward is higher but also
comedy never didn't have any boundaries
right so it's kind of that trap where
people get into where
you know the censorship seems like too
aggressive and it's affecting normal
people and
it seems like there's obviously this
issue here
and you kind of become this like
absolutist which in comedy
there's always if you go to if you walk
in to hang out with your friends right
and you or you walk in to hang out with
your parents
at a baptism you know there's a there's
different boundaries just socially right
and every room has different boundaries
and every platform has different
boundaries so these things always exist
so i think that it's better to point out
that like maybe something to take issue
with is that it seems to be
uh inconsistent and you know kind of
these boundaries just being used to
dismantle political opponents and
whatever and i think that's a problem
but
the idea that you should just be able to
say anything especially
um with people that it always switches
who's the one in power and who's the one
i mean
i remember watching uh bill o'reilly on
fox news and he was interviewing
and saying clown posse and if you took
the things he's saying
you could you could match them up almost
word for word with some of the things
that people on you know part of uh the
you know media class right now is saying
and it's you know
should you be saying these things
they're they're making people unsafe
and are is this bad for kids that you're
you know
whatever the the excuse that
they wanted to stop is always you know
safety of other people and it
always comes down to like a freedom
safety conversation and every country
kind of works out its own version of
that
canada it's it's that's one of the
reasons you know canada has
you know more of a safe culture and you
look at a lot of places and they have
their own versions of safe so it's
it's sort of a cultural conversation
that's like getting worked out in real
time
very loudly and there's a lot of
casualties of that
conversation but i don't know if there's
necessarily any right or wrong but
there's the one that i like better
you know there's the safety versus
freedom conversation probably depends on
what you like and i think that
i like the a more freedom-oriented
society because i think it breeds
greatness and i
i like competition and i like uh
you know pure competition i like
especially for myself
you know that's not necessarily a
commentary on like a corporate on the
political structure but
that's why i you know you know what i
mean so i think that that's why
this is very attractive to me i don't i
don't like i like to go into
a comedy club for example and no one
knows who anyone is and it's just who's
the best at this thing
so i think that um when it starts the
games all start to get rigged
i prefer a more free society and i
prefer
being able to navigate that by myself
but i understand why some other people
don't i mean you can see
certain people where freedom kind of
screws them up even on their own
personal life where they're like
you know i don't really have like a some
people even in this job you know and you
do something
obviously where you kind of figure out
your own hours and you figure out your
own path
and you must have seen other people in
your life where they
they kind of go into a job like that and
it's so bad for them
because you know they're they're not
good without structure and then
you cut when i feel like when these
people kind of get into fields like that
and then they go well this they want to
turn this into that
where they're like well there should be
a structure and then that's how you end
up with like well you go to this thing
and then you go to this job and then you
get this job at this place and
canada's their comedy's very like that
it's very you know
it's government subsidized in a lot of
ways you you you uh
you do comedy in the clubs here and then
you get this job here and then you can
maybe be a writer here and you work your
way up and they
they want to you know it's structured
almost like a government job especially
and
seniority is important and all these
sort of things and i think a lot of that
is to you know add
structure and take away freedom which
for some people
is preferable and for some people it's
not
you know what i find strange okay so
you're talking about
freedom versus freedom versus safety
basically
and and the weird it it is the
conversation yeah and
the weird thing i find is i'm very much
a freedom person
like i'm most comfortable or i'm most
comfortable
being in like a pool of chaos as long as
it's not
like as long as i can handle it right so
you don't want pure chaos but i like
you know having my own job and
traveling and if i'm in anything that's
kind of structured
i go crazy pretty quickly right but then
what's weird to me
is i always i to get into just to touch
politics a little bit
um i was always a liberal person
and now i identify more politically with
conservatives
and it's strange for me to see
the switch and so i'd like i'd like to
hear what you think about that but from
my point of view
conservatives are going towards freedom
and liberals are going towards safety
which is the opposite of what it was
when i was growing up
yeah i mean that's in my opinion that's
what
the the situation is right now because
that
their agendas are on the side of that um
so the what you know the liberals want
to accomplish involves removing freedom
and what the conservatives want to
accomplish you know and they're being
the the thought that is you know taboo
to say
is is their thought but that'll switch i
mean i i think you know i've
i i'm sure you've been along enough to
alive long enough to remember
the conservatives were once the ones
censoring people and all that stuff you
know
i like the idea of thinking of this yeah
a sketch where
liberals and conservatives from uh you
know 30 years ago
like time travel to now and they meet
and they meet the new conservatives
they're both like what is going on here
like like everything's switched that's a
good one you should do that one
and those so i you know i've i talked
kind of been thinking about this a lot
and talking about it but
i try not to attach myself to any of
those words because
they change a lot all the time and i
think that's
one of the big problems is with with
anything you know even in like punk
right now you kind of see this thing
about people being like
punk couldn't exist because of this this
stuff right now and they're
all having that same conversation but
really
the word sort of means something
different now and it's this subculture
has evolved in this is it
it's become this new thing and if you go
it's kind of the same thing they do with
well if black guys all think this this
is what marginalized people think and
then they sort of sp
or trans people think this and then when
you know caitlyn jenner or someone
doesn't think that it's
you know it's a whole hoopla because
that's what kind of happens right they
go
once they control the identities it's so
strong because then it becomes
i think liberals have that and it sounds
like you're
you know working that out or whatever
but i see you know people that probably
you guys know like the brett weinsteins
of the world i
i see these people constantly fighting
for the word liberal and being like
well i'm still liberal and i know that
they know it's true i know that in the
context
of everything no one thinks of that uh
but i'm actually it should be this and
you go the
the word means something different and
that's just
what the situation is and you can be the
last person saying well when i say [ __ ] i
mean a cigarette and that's you know
it's
no one you can fight those fights till
the end of time but
that's what happens with any culture as
it kind of
a lot of times the people that start it
leave and the people that left there are
sort of hall monitors
that's what's left at the end of the day
and then they use these
these kind of that's what and then also
people try to use that you know you're
not part of the thing you see in comedy
so much when it started the
the everyone's a nazi stuff right which
became kind of like a meme or whatever
right
but it is it's like rule one make a
group that's bad
and make it and then rule two put
everyone
you don't like in that group right so
you'll see that with conservatives with
the liberals because conservatives have
sort of recruiting members right now
where that's where someone like you that
probably isn't actually them
they get to go oh you you're part of us
now and you go okay maybe
but like once they're back in power
they're gonna be like okay if you're
here you need to think this and this
this and then you'll be kicked back out
so whenever a group's like looking for
power they're like letting everyone in
whereas that's who the liberals used to
be whereas before
they would be claiming you they they'd
be going no no she's a liberal where now
they see themselves as like the power so
they can have these strict things that
they you know like a church where they
want people to
abide by it and then they get to go well
everyone who doesn't agree you better
do this list of things unless you want
to be called a conservative and everyone
goes
well i don't want to be called a
conservative i better you know get in
line with these beliefs
i think you know it doesn't work with
like everyone there's a certain people
that are
naturally contributing and critical
thinkers and stuff like that and i'm
sure that you fall under that category
so you go
all right well whatever then call me
that i don't care i'm gonna i'm not
changing my beliefs because
you want to give some title on me right
oh yeah no no no i'm not changing my
beliefs
definitely for not for any title i've
just noticed that i won't
i'm not as welcome to talk like i'll
talk to anybody
i'll have anybody on my podcast yeah and
there are people who are like no
i won't talk to you because you're one
of x
and then which is frustrating and i find
that
most of that like inability to
communicate
isn't coming from conservatives to tell
you the truth
even though i don't agree like i'm not
i'm i'm really not particularly
conservative i'm having exactly the same
conversation brett weinstein was
probably half
having but like either taking your
identity away
yeah or trying to stick me in some sort
of box what do you say so you just avoid
the entire topic you're like i'm not
even getting into that
well it's not that i avoided the topic
it's that
i mean i i don't listen i've never voted
i consider myself okay you know a
cultural commentator and
and i and a comedian and i think that
all of that has been intertwined with
politics and especially in the donald
trump years
political uh politics and culture have
been intertwined and they've been
intertwined with oh yeah
i mean listen if you're an athlete you
need to begin to you know have
a political uh affiliation if you're an
actor
if you're a you know a ceo if
whatever you are you need to weigh in on
this so in a lot of ways i
you know my friend is a funny thing uh
that he said that
you get it's like we got you got drafted
to the culture war
because they basically said you know
we're gonna you know you have to go
along with this and this and this and
you go no and it's like okay well in
that case you're like against us and you
go
okay you know but i think that at this
point they've done that to too many
people but
i'm not gonna pretend that i'm uh
you know care who the president is i
just don't
i'm i think that i probably
would be the i'm i'm up for um
uh i don't know what the best way to
describe it is i'm like a
someone that i feel like i would be
being courted and it's like
well here's what i want which doesn't
sound like either of you are exactly
that i mean
i'm better for comedy like you know i
mean if one of
yeah if one of you guys are like saying
that hey let's shut down the speech on
the internet and one of you aren't then
okay
at this moment i think that you know
that's the
important issue for me and i'm i'd
probably be a single issue voter if i
did care to vote but i've
probably never lived anywhere that a
vote mattered anyway but
um you know yeah but
so i i kind of see it like that where i
go you know those words
your parties have changed in both of
these
places have changed they they're they're
going to have a trans republican
and you know the liberals are against
refugees i mean in seven years the
amount that this
changes sort of me it to me it to for me
that like my whole thing is my opinions
and
my you know perspective and all that
stuff i'm gonna now let you be in
control of that
so if i said i was any of these words
they now have control of what i do
or who how people see me and i think
that's the i go
i i i'm not going to uh
agree to that at the very least that
they're they can keep trying to
you know do it by being like well if
you're not with us you're against us and
i go
yeah i just you think that do do the
majority
of people think that you think they do i
don't i don't see it
you know what i mean i don't see that
when i'm talking to normal people
that they that they agree to that that
if i don't subscribe to all this stuff
i'm in the bad group i think that
you i think that a lot of people on the
internet would like that to be the case
but i don't think it is
yeah well i think all that's been
exacerbated terribly with covid and
people being isolated because the only
people they were seeing were people on
the internet
it definitely did i well for me okay so
i was talking a lot about this kind of
stuff that i'm talking about now
five years ago you know like 2015 there
was
you know kind of the little edgy boy
whatever right like
you know that's when stuff real that's
when it really started to be like not
okay to say this stuff
2015 was probably when it really started
to be like here's the
opinions you have to have and i think i
was
you know saying and on
what i would see is like truths that
you're not supposed to say
and so i i think someone like ricky
gervais he he
describes it more as i'm saying
jokes and the audience knows they're
wrong that's why they're laughing and i
think a lot of times he
and that that is one but i'd say in my
opinion i think it's a little closer to
you're saying stuff that's true but
you're not supposed to say it
i think that's probably a little closer
to what i i i think's happening
but then i kind of stopped talking about
this because i felt like it was
you know i almost like you had what you
turned into a thing
well yeah it definitely turned into a
thing
and then also i felt like people agreed
with me so
you know on the internet you know what i
mean this idea that this
you know everyone's a nazi kind of thing
whatever you want to call that right i'm
sure there's a million words for it
but that idea of everyone's you know
pointing fingers and
white guys are the worst you know i kind
of liked that the idea that you stepped
on stage and there's this
energy that you're the bad guy like i
kind of found a way to sort of make that
work comedically
but when i honest to god by like 2017-18
i started feel like i would push back
against something that wasn't really
there
i always felt like that i was on stage
talking to your average person
and i felt like they kind of agreed with
me that this stuff went too far and that
was the energy that i was feeling
and then so i was moving away from that
and i was talking a lot about
the men and women and i was that i was
really like focused on
sort of way more gender and and i was
kind of back to talking about
you know uh for lack of a better word
like sociology like the
you know race and differences but i was
just saying these things without
using the context of like i know i'm not
supposed to say this right i was just
kind of
doing comedy again and then in in
in covid this bubbled back back up to
the point where
i felt back to how i felt in 2015. so my
internal gauge felt
the same way that you're describing okay
i think i saw exactly the same thing
from the outside not from comedy
where everybody's like it's all it's all
going through the same path yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so 2016 was
particularly bad and then it calmed down
a little bit and then covet hit and it
kind of looked like
all of the the kind of like the
sociological
problems were having it kind of looked
like those were gonna die like that no
one was gonna care about that for a
while i thought
for like three months and then it blew
up
yeah it felt like i think that's what
happened and it felt like there was
a consensus to some degree between
normal people
if that makes sense and that's kind of
probably the thing that i feel like i
have the
most uh of a gauge of because that's
what i do
three times a night is i take a random
sample of normal people and
you know find out what their opinions
are in the form of you know
asking them to laugh and finding out
what they agree with and don't agree
with it and you kind of
learn to feel that i think and
the when you know george floyd happened
and all of these things
coveted they all became things that the
social ramifications of going against
the you know a kind of small minority
became so high that i think a lot of
people that
were got back in line so it's almost
like
a lot of these events allowed them to
like wrangle you know people that maybe
didn't care back into okay maybe i don't
care but i'll say i do
so they kind of they were they were able
to like work yeah
but you know to say that
to go back to like what you said that i
it's worse on you know one side um
i i i obviously that the specific
you know thing i think it's objective
truth that it's one side yelling at
people right now i know
yeah i don't so i don't think that's
controversial but i do
think the the tribalism you know
component in the group think is
happening everywhere
i mean even in if you look at if you say
like your conservative commentators that
all
rose up right um those people
when they step out of line of what
they're supposed to say you can even see
everyone
getting mad at them you know it's like
people being like hey what you're
supposed to be the guy that thinks this
and you go
well i'm not your puppet you know i have
my own opinions and
so when it when when they both become so
rigid i
i see why it's impossible to hear
criticisms from the other side and i
think that's one of the reasons why
comedians are
um best when they're unbiased i mean
you'll see people and commentate a lot
of people at best when they're biased
but
i think about this one kind of a lot to
think of it the other way around right
do you know how okay i would i would
honestly use your dad as an example of
this
like when anyone your average person
thinks he's sick like your average dude
is like yo that guy rules
that would be my opinion right and when
you
so anyone that thinks that when you see
people on the internet saying he said
this and this you go ah he's just
looking for something you you
you would dismiss their criticisms so
imagine now
you were someone that was all in on
black lives matter or all in on trans
stuff
and then you see a conservative being
like well on the black lives matter
website it says this and this you go
shut up you're just looking for
something oh yeah you have an honest
critique of this
like in what scenario would you be for
this
so i think that they are i think that
i get why both sides see critiques from
the other side as
you know in bad faith and they're
a lot of times both right and that
doesn't mean there
there isn't critiques of something but
it does mean that i
i wouldn't listen to that i mean listen
imagine you know uh you're
you're talking to some imagine you're
you're you're married right
yeah right yeah and then uh imagine you
know some girl was telling you
uh you know i think that your husband's
bad and you're giving you some
critiques and then you find out everyone
told you she's been trying to have sex
with him for ten you go well
what the hell am i listening to you you
don't have a you know you're not useful
here
you're obviously a partisan component of
this with an agenda
so it is hard to listen to people that
have an agenda that's like
that you're bad yeah oh yeah oh yeah for
sure
it's just i mean it's complicated too
because most of the people i follow are
conservative i would say
um so it's hard for me to to know what
the average view out there is
and i would argue because you're saying
that you have maybe more of an
average view of society but you're also
putting up
are you putting up videos that you think
the right and the left both
find equally funny well i've done
um so i don't know if i necessarily have
an average view of society
i think i have a pulse on what the
average view of society is
and then i use that to you know push
them in different places
but um so
my biggest videos before the woke racist
one was
uh how fox how you sell footage to fox
news and cnn
and it was how i you know take the parts
that fox news would like
and send them to them and take the parts
that that cnn would like and sell it to
them
and then i did a video of of you know a
a guy that loves trump and a guy that
hates trump that live in the same house
and then i kind of did
so i think i've seen that i think i've
seen that one a lot of these videos went
like very viral so i've had a lot of
so in a lot of ways you know everyone
probably you know everyone has their
different version of how they see
someone and unfortunately you don't get
to control that as much as you
but in a lot of ways i was sort of you
know when you say what my
my thing that i was becoming known for
was almost
you know that i was making fun of both
sides and
the problem is on the you know people
that are part of the radical left
or whatever you want to call them you
know they they don't accept that the
both sides are bad they
their argument is they go well you're a
guy that's looking at hitler and a
mailman and you're like well maybe
they're both bad like that's how they
see it and you go
yeah obviously they don't see it like
that and obviously i don't see the world
like that
where it's like one side is just this
shape that's so great and the other side
is evil like bad
and i was like yeah i mean if your world
view is that simplistic and reductionist
then yeah that would be i i guess you
would see the world that way
but obviously i don't see the world that
way
but the that is one of the biggest
things that i think that
you know the let's say the hall monitors
of the world are
so wrong about with with people like me
and even when you say you follow
conservative people i mean maybe a lot
of them probably
you know used to call themselves
liberals or whatever right like i think
that
yeah yeah i guess i'm this now how many
times can you get call the
you know the thing before you go okay
whatever if you want to change the words
and that's what i'm in
i haven't changed but if you guys want
to change the things
but yeah i follow people i don't follow
i don't necessarily follow conservatives
i follow people who don't apologize for
thinking yeah which
i think that that's the probably the two
you know the two dissonant voices is
probably
i you know when we talk about comedy i
think that a lot of people want to put
some people in a box but the best way to
describe them is
guy people that aren't going with the
program whatever that program is and if
you switch the program
they wouldn't go with that program
either so you know with that program
right now happens to be like a
you know corporate you know activism
thing or whatever right
but um whenever i do people have this
like idea of they think that
they know they can speak for other
groups right because
like i said once you kind of control all
the identities you get to control them
and they go well these people think like
this and you go
yeah but when i do if i'm in a you know
like for example
i do comedy that will do almost
i do really well in like black rooms
just there's like a whole
cohort of toronto that has that scene
and i was you know like kind of my
friends were that in the comedy scene
or whatever so i would do a lot of those
rooms and i was actually really
uh my sentiment really like resonated in
those rooms that was kind of a thing
that
i was pretty good at but then i would
put those jokes on the internet
and people would go oh this is guy
you're racist you're doing this thing
you know
and you go this is comedy that literally
does well for black people
are the jokes that i i get tons of
people that i'm like i'm all i'm this i
don't consider myself this or i'm a
liberal i'm a conservative
and i like your comedy because you know
i don't have to agree with you all the
time but i think your comedy i just did
my video i i i because i'm do mostly
youtube and i'm
fairly doing male driven comedy i think
i think i'm
especially because of the way the world
went i i kind of
uh i would say that i'm speaking to men
and i
and on stage actually i'll talk about
that second but my point is
i did a video which is clearly making
fun of women
uh the two i've done two videos which
are clearly you know kind of
uh uh like [ __ ] disturbing dig at women
right and those videos were
my most popular videos with women that
i've had you know what i mean
so yeah that's not that surprising it's
not like that's
you know it's a bit surprising yeah well
because i'm talking about something that
they agree with they go
i've seen this too that's you know and
as long as it's like accurate and honest
and they think that you understand the
thing it's
and it's not in bad faith or whatever
yeah
so i try to it's not in bad faith that's
important yeah i think
so when i describe the women men thing i
say you kind of speak to
men with you can speak to women
sometimes with energy
in a way that allows you to speak to men
with words
that they wouldn't like sometimes kind
of the
do you know what i mean like the idea
that okay go get into that get into that
a little bit more
this is my this is like a ryan long
theory that
probably maybe people don't like but
you would um okay how many times have
you heard a girl say
um i i i didn't like this guy or like
this guy on a date within the first five
seconds
you know and that kind of intuition yeah
so they have that with everyone right
i mean so you you can have a girl watch
two comedians that can do the exact same
act and some of them i really agreed
with that guy who's really funny and the
other guy be like i didn't
you know my mom's like the queen of that
it's just all energy you know i mean you
go what did he say and you go i just you
know something about him
oh yeah i have that terribly
i have that terrible way i'm not gonna
like oh yeah i know and i've decided
just just to go with that it's like yeah
i don't like that person i don't know
why
i do not like that person and i don't
think it's gonna change
i think a lot of times pattern
recognition i don't know what it is
exactly and your intuition's informed a
lot of times
and it's you know a lot of times it can
be correct
but doesn't mean it can't be hacked for
one and
you know but um yeah but for two
you could look at it the other way
around where it's an old trope
men aren't as in tune with that where
they're essentially stupider
you know it's like the guy that's around
his girlfriend and she's like you didn't
notice that i'm mad you idiot
you know what i mean you go what like
you're i've been stomping around the
house angry
and you know it's like the oldest thing
in the book but whereas a girl
you know would be a little closer on
average right a little more in tune with
you know what's wrong
so in a lot of ways it's you you if if
you can kind of
uh in i i think on stage this is what i
think that i've become pretty good at is
saying
different things to guys and girls at
the same time and it's
so it's almost the equivalent of you
know making a joke about
let's say you made a joke about women
and your energy to women is like
obviously i'm kidding
and your energy to men's like i'm not
though
okay okay i enti i know exactly where
you're coming from
that's funny okay that's funny um
you said something just a second ago
you're like obviously you can hack that
okay
so how do you hack that okay so not
letting that one go either
so on a the you know the most aggressive
level
it would be the guy that is really good
at
getting women but he's a sociopath you
know there's
there's a guy out there that you know
has hacked how to make women like him
and
fall in love with him you know and you
can do that
there's there's people that so it's
harder to i'm saying it's harder to
you know um uh
use energy to manipulate men in the same
way
with men you have to like structurally
manipulate them almost because they're
too stupid to notice your manipulations
so with women uh someone that
was really a master of like energy and
all that stuff i mean that's what like
pick-up artists do they're essentially
like
trying to hack a woman but it's in your
normal life it's not something you want
to do i don't think because you don't
want
you know who wants relationships where
the whole thing is you're like yeah
i'm tricking them the whole time and
over time it won't work
because over time you have to like live
up to this hack
because eventually if you've been with
this person for any
period of time the amount of evidence
that you were
you know the they'll eventually be like
you know realize this is a fraud
but on the short term when there's no
you know i'll tell you what there's no
negative consequences of
hacking someone's emotions in a comedy
club to make them have a good time
i mean there's no victim here yeah
okay that's very cool i can remember in
high school having my girlfriends be
like you know
i'm giving this guy all the signs he has
no idea that i'd like him
and and i remember telling them
literally you have to full-on say i have
a crush on you or i like you like you
it has to be that obvious or they're not
gonna get it they're like shoulder
brushes and things that you do in high
school they're not
showing up i don't know what's wrong
with these people but you just have to
tell them because
they're not ignoring you they don't get
it yeah i remember the oldest dad yeah
i've kind of said the if you
all the stuff that kind of masquerades
is right left or
you know authoritarian not authoritarian
or freedom
safety i think so many of them
uh i you know boil down to girl guy
where it's like
you know even you take these issues like
you know some
you know the cultural figures where it's
like the the left hates him in the right
house it's like
no like joe rogan if you it's like
but so you know most dudes think he's
sick and most girls
kind of don't like him like you know
what i mean it's like
it's as if they made action movies you
know this
political thing where it's like you like
action movies that's a right wing thing
and it's like
no dudes kind of think this is sick and
most girls like poo poo it
and you can kind of look at some of the
other cultural figures you know
whatever oprah most girls thought she
was sick and most guys are like what is
this garbage
so i think that a lot of times there's a
lot of different ways to break up this
kind of culture war that isn't just
that isn't only political or uh
yeah i would actually break it down a
little bit differently i would
and my dad has some evidence of this um
doing kind of large-scale psychological
tests that he used to do
yeah i know that's psychological tests
yeah agreeable people
so women tend to be more agreeable right
yeah but
but you get the agreeable men who also
end up having the same opinion
as a lot of women because they're more
agreeable so rather than i mean i guess
you know it doesn't really matter if
you're talking about men versus well
you'd say
feminism yeah or disagreeable agreeable
yeah but if if then if then you go okay
well men are more agreeable but and you
make a list of these things then i guess
you could just be like
you know as a broad generalization if
you're you know being
whatever sociological about it uh using
averages
i'm being sociological yeah or is that
psychological whatever i just don't want
to be lumped in
with all the women who don't have a
sense of humor here no
they just have a different sense of
humor you know i've seen so many times
where um people like you know someone
that's kind of
speaking to them i mean i i've seen so
many times i'mma ride this friend and i
won't mention her name because it isn't
i don't know if it's positive or
negative but i remember so many times
we were do we would do this comedy club
which was very
i would say masculine orient and one of
those was because it was sort of the
comedy club of the people that were
troublemakers or whatever right
and then girls actually started
boycotting the club right and then
they would have girls being like there's
no girls in this club and you're like
well half of your boycotting it so
that's kind of what happens and then
girls would get mad at other girls they
go if you do that club you're in the you
know how they
the girls oh yeah they called each other
right so it kind of became that but i
had a friend
there was a girl the girl that she's
like i think she's one of the funniest
people but she would
i remember let's say my the girl i was
dating at the time or some
friends that i was girls with would be
at the club right and then three guys
would like kill right you know you'd
have like a hot crowd where
two or three guys would have just like
the best sets and then she would have
maybe like a lukewarm set kind of you
know fine but it
clearly wasn't the best set of the night
objectively and then you'd go with your
girl and she'd be like that girl was
like really funny i really liked her and
you go
she had the worst set of the night i go
what are you stupid like but
not actually if you know what i mean but
i i would be like what are you
nuts like she bombed basically but
in her that's the person that kind of
scratched an itch for her
are you are you sure that she wasn't
just being nice though
because women will also do that no it's
because
they this it's like you know when you uh
watch a have you ever watched something
where like it wasn't the best thing that
stuck in your brain like a little worm
that wouldn't get out of there
it's like they had these little lines
where she was like that one's thing she
said that's so true and it's like
you they kind of she kind of like
articulated something they were trying
to think about
you know as girls we do this and this
and they go that and it kind of like
gets in their head and they're
that girl ruled like you know what i
mean so even though
so it was kind of better for them even
though it maybe didn't get more laughs
and i think that
that's just that uh in a lot of things
people kind of watch things where they
go oh
yo that guy's that guy rules like that's
exactly what i've been trying to say
and i think that uh sometimes we you
know everyone sees that in a different
thing
and it's not so i think i think i have i
think i just have a really hard time
understanding certain things like if i
don't find something funny
seriously if i don't find something
funny i'm like that's just not funny
objectively like it's not if i don't
find it funny it's not funny which
obviously is not how
the world works and i understand that
but i don't like feel that
um i know i have like a group of people
that are like
you're either a friends person or a
you're a seinfeld person
right and friends isn't funny
right for me just like that's just not i
can't
picture i can't put myself in a place
where i find that funny
but i guess some people don't find
seinfeld funny and think friends
is funny and i don't understand that
well yeah i i think that one of the
things that
uh starts to suck about you know all of
this
uh you know war and all this stuff right
in the culture whether you got trapped
but they go
just because something isn't
entirely objective doesn't mean it's
subjective and just because it's like
there is some subjective component so
yeah you're
there is like an objective component but
there is a sorry i'm
like muddling this thing but my point is
it's kind of like
we start it's like we start saying that
there's some subjectivity and then be
like people
use that to be like yeah so there's no
there's no good or bad
and be like no yes there is good and bad
and there is things that are better but
there is obviously
it's the equivalent of you know if you
look at pretty
beauty standards or whatever right they
do change
kind of across you know if you go to one
place they might think one thing's
hotter than the other
but that doesn't mean if we show a
supermodel and a 900 pound
girl that's conventionally unattractive
that they're they're not all gonna agree
this one's hotter than this one so there
is like objectivity
but there's just like subjectivity
within that scale because
everyone's not uniform so there's
definitely
there is comedy that is objectively
better you know
but it's just you probably need to go
pretty far down the
uh on the span so you can it is
objective fact that dave chappelle
is better than my dad at stand-up comedy
that is an objective fact
but is dave chappelle better than jerry
seinfeld that is a subjective fact
probably because you know in that realm
it's it's there's peop there's probably
dis disagreement among
community there's disagreement among
people if you ask some
you know jewish mother in miami she
probably thinks jerry seinfeld is
funnier if you ask you know
some uh hipster in new york or maybe
that's that's a bad example of who would
like chappelle but
you know whatever right now yeah yeah
exactly you can think of whoever right i
mean jerry simon was kind of the
original
brooklyn hipster in a lot of ways or
whatever yeah
that's fair okay uh who who do you
think's the funniest comedian now right
now
so i think that they're
i kind of look at it uh
in terms of there's like a really cool
counterculture of people that sort of
are clearly doing something great that
they're
kicked out of the you know not being
welcomed into the mainstream
which kind of forced everyone to create
this whole
other world which is actually bigger and
better
in a lot of ways so if i was to say the
people like the
i think that there's a lot of really
funny people in new york and you know
the
kind of like tim dillon's andrew schultz
and kurt metzger is you know someone
that i
really find funny and uh the jokers in
the legion of skanks guys
i think that there's these kind of
dissonant voices that are
you know really honed and really know
who they are i think that those p
i think those are some of like the
greatest comics right now in a lot of
ways
people are greater than they would have
been because they were kicked out of
you know like i i think if you look at
someone like me
probably if you looked at
10 years ago what would the closest
person to
someone like me and i don't think we do
comedy that similar
but if you look at just from what i look
like maybe how i make people feel
might be like a daniel tosh or someone
like that you know what i mean ah okay
yeah
and i i love daniel yeah and there's a
ton of differences but if you just said
you know this type of guy kind of you
know
trouble whatever i think that that's
probably what a career trajectory
for a you know white guy that looks like
me
that kind of you know what i mean so
that's but i think
but because people like me aren't
welcome in what you would call
mainstream you know hollywood comedy
you actually stay away from this thing
that makes you way worse
so you know being and then now that you
and then once you build your own thing
and once you have money and you don't
really need these people it's like
some of these people are doing very very
well and they don't need any of that
stuff anymore
it really allows you to be way better at
comedy so
there's a lot of these people that are
really having a moment and they're
their voices are shining so bright for
lack of a better word
because they you know that sounds lame
but like
because they weren't they were kicked
out of the club that stifles your voice
yeah that is a very interesting way of
thinking it about it
and youtube and podcasting has really
given people a platform to basically say
whatever they want unless
you know in specific instances that
doesn't go well but
a lot of these like you said not always
yeah but a lot of these kind of more
i don't know what you'd call them
alternative comedians i guess
a disney yeah i do have it like yeah
yeah yeah voices
they do have massive platforms dissonant
voices
[Laughter]
yeah okay i i can go along with that but
uh they do have massive platforms
which is nice yeah i mean um when you
look at these industry people i mean
you know that's why in canada people
there isn't much going on so it's like
you know these
these sort of middle management comedy
jobs or you know people
look want them and and and here they
want them to and they pay a lot of money
but now and you know i'm doing very well
but i've only been here for a
year and a half and really in the kind
of american
uh light and you know i got cash or
whatever but like i have friends that
are
millionaires you know you know a few
times over
so when you go into a meeting at comedy
central now and it's kind of like oh we
might be able to
give you this you know like for example
snl like those kind of jobs right
you know i've had managers and agents
try to push me towards that and they're
like hey we want you audition for
and you go dude i'm like i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go take a a subway up to
midtown
for like a 60-hour a week job
then i'm already more popular than some
of the people that work there and on top
of that
i probably won't thrive in that
environment and then on top of that i
get paid less
you go what do you talk what what are
you talking about
why for what and you it's like well
maybe you know you can kind of enter
this legacy position and maybe
a movie star i go i don't even know if
that's really happening like that
anymore and if it is it is definitely
not happening for people like me
so i think that you know i think that a
lot of people are too
glued to what it used to be and that's
where that like victim complex comes
from because they
saw this thing and they saw these people
become movie stars and they saw this
thing and they wanted that and then
you know it's kind of not available
anymore and they're like well i can't do
this but
you know yeah if you're working at a job
and and they'd stop
they go if you're if you're someone
working a job and they go
we really are going the other way we're
not looking for you
uh yeah i mean that sucks
but i think you gotta move the same way
that this has always happened there's
always been an in vogue
comedy i mean i think bill burr has
mentioned this but
you know everyone's kind of seen it but
there was a while where there was
always some new you know funny fat
neighbor that was blowing up
and then you know that was the and then
there was some new you know white video
game nerd that was the hot guy and
it's always sort of changing what the in
vogue industry darling is and right now
it's
clear what that is and you know that you
can complain about that or
whatever you can be the other thing
yeah i saw i saw bill burr in budapest
and i almost
i swear that show almost killed me i
don't think i've
ever not breathed for i'm alive i
managed to survive it but
i've i've never laughed that hard at
anything in my entire life
he's so funny yeah he's so funny in
person
it's ridiculous yeah i i literally had
to almost leave because i wasn't
breathing
it was it was great um yeah i tried okay
i've i feel like i've tried to take a
few
uh things from all of the big people you
know that i consider the best whether it
be louie or
all these people and burr resonated a
little less
to me personally although i think he's
great like i've
watched some of his best he's so
horrible he's so oh he's i mean he's
phenomenal at it but i think the thing
that i liked that's applicable to
everything that i heard him say once was
no matter what you're doing there's
always
something that you can get better at and
that's the pursuit
of ins you can't just do the thing you
do it's like
once you're on stage um be like i don't
i can't i don't i can't tell a nine
minute story and this guy can can i tell
a nine minute story
that kills as hard as the rest of my
stuff and i i started
doing that because of burr when i was in
toronto i started being like
i would i would see someone do a joke
and be like i can't tell a joke like
that
like a joke that um you know let's say a
joke that had a
45 second build up and then a huge punch
line and i
maybe i i see someone do that i go ah i
don't have the guts or i couldn't pull
that off
and i started trying to conquer those
little things and i think that that was
like a
burr thing that i took that i think made
me a lot better at comedy and i do that
with videos too i go
can i do that can i do a a video like
that you know what i mean could i
could i conquer a video where there is
where it feels like
nothing's happening and i hold that yeah
for two minutes or something you know
what i mean
so you start doing yeah you're trying to
like conquer these little weird things
and it makes you better at it that's
great that's the like that's gotta be my
favorite type of humor
or it's like my my dad he's not a
comedian but he's pretty good at
when he's on stage or something or in a
lecture going on about something and
it'll be like
10 minutes and uh and i'll be listening
being like how
what does this have to do with where we
started and how is he going to bring it
back
right and then it it he brings it back
and and it's like that was so cool
it seemed full of like years of yeah and
yeah if comedians can do that and just
stretch out that tension like you said
so you're like where is this going
what's happening what's going on
oh and then everything clicks that's
amazing and you bring it all back
and then yeah i was doing one where it
was like yeah the idea that the
punchline like you you kind of
keep just going back to the same thing i
remember ricky gervais was doing that in
his
special and that's that british thing
where he kept being like
it was so small but his joke was about
that caitlyn jenner
you know crashed her car and killed
someone right and she
he ricky gervais did three jokes
where he pretended that he was going to
talk about something else and then the
punchline was just
back to her crashing the car and it was
kind of
and you're just like man like how did
you pull that off like the fourth time
and you kind of see it's like and and
you and sometimes the answer is you
couldn't you know that's that's
that's their specific skill and yeah the
thing that you can do i think
you know my my thing that um
that probably that if if i was being
honest or if
other people were summing it up that i'm
able to do that no one else is able to
do is i'm allowed to
i'm able to say i have like a innocence
in my personality that allows me to you
know bring people along for horrendous
journeys
so i so i can i can sort of take people
to pretty aggressive places
in like and you're still sympathetic
because of whatever my
energy as a human being is at least on
stage
yeah that's great that's why i guess you
use the comparison to daniel tosh right
he looks so innocent when he's talking
about such horrible things his eyebrows
are up
just like sympathy i think i honestly
just yeah it's i think
i think i use the daniel toss thing
because it's i just like a
you know whatever normal looking white
dude that everyone thinks is a douchebag
that kind of gets away with saying
aggressive stuff
i mean we actually do comedy pretty
differently but i think that's why
yeah i think it's just i'm just saying
how the public when
when he came into hollywood when he
showed up to hollywood
i think that they would see him you know
if you worked at a desk on hollywood and
you go what do we do with this guy
i think they would see us similar if
that makes sense
i feel like they'd be more worried about
you probably
coming from an outside view limbo loose
cannon dude
okay ryan thank you very much for coming
on uh if people want to
check out your podcast uh or find you
online where do they go
yeah thanks a lot for having me on the
boys cast with ryan long is my podcast
and i release a video uh every monday
at ryan long comedy and that's youtube
ryan long comedy and
all the other platforms are that too and
then patreon.com
the boyzcast if you want to give me a
million dollars
cool i will link all those below thanks
again
all right thanks mikaya
[Music]
you